[Musique]
samedi aux quatre coins du québec c'est
la grande journée des petits
entrepreneurs c'est une occasion de
vivre une première expérience en
entrepreneuriat pour les jeunes de 5 à
17 ans avec nous ce soir un jeune
entrepreneur nos épaules les tbonds soir
et puis andréanne rochette qui est
directrice des opérations de la grande
journée des petits entrepreneurs bonsoir
bonsoir c'est fini d'abord c'est quoi la
grande journée des petits entrepreneurs
la grande journée des petits
entrepreneurs c'est un événement qui a
vu le jour en 2014 l'objectif c'est
d'offrir la chance aux jeunes de 5 à 17
ans de réaliser un projet donc une
petite entreprise doit un jour donc
finalement d'explorer l'entrepreneuriat
par ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on a
l'occasion de faire nécessairement dans
la vie de tous les jours donc l'idée
c'est d'inviter les jeunes à créer un
projet quel qu'il soit donc souvent les
jeunes vont se fier à leur leur passion
leur intérêt est de monter un projet
donc ils vont présenter le jour de
l'événement qu'ils disent mais
finalement le 4 juin présenter ou devant
en fait les enfants ont l'occasion de le
présenter devant la résidence donc un
kiosque on peut penser au fameux kiosque
de limonade à tout le monde cette image
là en tête donc devant la résidence très
simple familial puis on est certains
jeunes aussi en fait plusieurs jeunes à
travers le québec qui vont aussi
participer à travers des marchés de
petit entrepreneur dont on a plusieurs
bénévoles on a des organisations aussi
qu'ils se mettent ensemble pour avoir
finalement un regroupement un marché
finalement de petit entrepreneur pour
faciliter aussi les visites lors la
jambe noé toi tu es un petit
entrepreneur que je trouve bien grand
quand même puis ça fait plusieurs années
qu'ils participent oui donc moi en fait
j'ai participé à la grande journée dès
la deuxième édition je me suis parti une
entreprise qui faisaient des noeuds
papillon oui avec des modèles originaux
qui se mettait aussi en serre tête j'ai
parti avec ma petite soeur à l'époque
j'avais 10 ans et maintenant je rendais
à 17 ans fait que pour moi ça c'est ma
dernière année sa boucle un pull à la
longue boucle que ça a été pour moi mais
l'entreprise existe toujours oui une
entreprise existe aux jo mais je vais
vous avouer que
parce que je suis passé à l'émission
dans l'oeil du dragon il ya quelques
années et
après la parution de l'émission ça m'a
vraiment enseveli complètement sous la
demande complètement ça s'est toujours
bien passé mais là ça s'est un peu trop
bien passé c'est vrai ça s'est un peu
trop bien passé un gros problème c'est
un beau problème oui que jeu qui m'a
permis d'en apprendre beaucoup et qui
m'a notamment donné beaucoup de
confiance en moi la grande journée des
petits entrepreneurs en général je pense
que c'est vraiment un bel événement qui
donne beaucoup de confiance en soi aux
jeunes qui participent et donc était
toujours entrepreneurs oui je m'en vais
l'année prochaine en business and
entrepreneurship au collège champlain ok
donc je mange mais je continue dans ce
chemin et là c'est vraiment quelque
chose qui me passionne que j'aime
beaucoup et alors qu'est ce que vous
proposez andré une recette aux jeunes
quels outils quelles accompagnement
qu'elle produit qu'est ce que vous
proposez aux jeunes pour les indes et
justement devenir entrepreneur on a des
outils en fait qu'ils sont disponibles
pour les parents et pour les enfants et
les adolescents parce qu'effectivement
c'est pas nécessairement évident de
partir une entreprise ou petites
entreprises on le sait pas
nécessairement donc on a des guides des
outils qui sont disponibles lors des
inscriptions
donc ça peut être des idées finalement
pour les biens communs commun qu'on la
trouve la fameuse idée d'entreprise ou
si c'est souvent suffit à nous à nos
passions à nos intérêts communs qu'on va
trouver notre nom d'entreprise la triste
comme on veut qu'est-ce qu'on a besoin
pour mettre l'entreprise en marche en
fonction par exemple si on pense à un
kiosque de limonade dont il va falloir
de l'autre citron du sucre est forte
alors que j'achète c'est ce que j'aime
ici parce que je lis ou est ce que je
veux savoir que je demande un prêt à mes
parents ou amis grands parents qui sait
est-ce que je vais avoir besoin des
douits justement lui dans son entreprise
au parti entreprise avec réaliste quand
elle avait 5 ans donc ça petit train et
donc on est toutes ces notions le
finalement leur que les jeunes vont
apprendre en cours de route thomert par
leurs projets nourrissent et en quelles
compétences pour devenir entrepreneur
pour devenir un entrepreneur en général
et surtout pour les jeunes de cet
événement là je pense que ça prend de
l'originalité
de l' enthousiasme et juste avoir
confiance en soi parce que ça travaux
leur gros et ça peut avoir l'air
difficile mais si c'est ça justement de
déplacer sans petites étapes et
justement prendre chaque problème un an
la fois ça donne beaucoup de confiance
en soi et je trouve que c'est quelque
chose de très important c'est la
neuvième édition gagner de la confiance
en soi puis vouloir être entrepreneur
pire rester entrepreneur c'est une chose
est ce qu'il y en a beaucoup des noës
comme ça qui est alice qui se sont
lancés dans la grande journée qui sont
devenus entrepreneurs avez vous beaucoup
d'exemples on a plusieurs jeunes qui
participent année après année à
l'événement saucier c'est un très très
haut pourcentage c'est certain que nos
îles c'est pas la norme nécessairement
de devoir aussi fermer l'entreprise
paraît par un trop grasse et un grand
succès le même l'arrêt de l'entreprise
c'est quand même beau problème que vous
avez dit militer l'idée derrière la
grande journée c'est pas que tous les
jeunes qui participent deviennent des
entrepreneurs mais vraiment acquiert des
qualités entrepreneuriales qui pour nous
sont super importante dont justement on
enferme la confiance en soi la fierté le
savoir qu'on est capable de monter un
projet donc de a à z donc d'avoir cette
confiance l'eau pour aller au-devant
croire en ses rêves fille allait
faire tout ce qu'on souhaite finalement
donc oui on va en des entrepreneurs
d'autres qui vont intégrer finalement
ces qualités là peu importe ce qu'ils
vont devenir la grande journée et demain
donc une carte sur le site web où on
peut voir où sont les jeunes absolument
qu'on a une carte interactive ont aussi
une application mobile petits
entrepreneurs au plus réel que l'on peut
télécharger à la maison soit sort à
apple ou ou android vous pouvez regarder
dans le fonds directement la en ligne
avec le code poster donc pour ce faire
un itinéraire à l'encourager le plus de
jeunes possible parce qu'il est donc il
vous attend demain nous attendent un
grand grand nombre de 4000 jeunes à
travers le québec dont dix îles de la
madeleine dans sap r/3 bière montréal
québec et à travers l'écrit et nourrit
toi tu vas rester un entrepreneur j'ai
bien mûri ce wee cc c'est mon désir et
c'est ce que je vise oui et
je me rappelle les expériences à travers
les grandes journées que j'ai eu avec ma
petite sortie de voir l' enthousiasme si
des clients qui ont vraiment pris le
temps de se déplacer pour venir voir le
kiosque sais d expérience que je vais
jamais oublier pour de vrai j'encourage
tout le monde à aller encourager domaine
en tout cas vous avez l'air heureux de
votre expérience nous et nos épaules
l'été épandre ian rush est merci
beaucoup merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit